-There are just five,
count 'em, five days left
in Donald Trump's presidency.
His White House
is being boxed up.
He's now the only president in
history to be impeached twice,
and he's turning on some
of his closest allies.
including his personal lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Yesterday, Trump became
the first president in history
to be impeached twice --
this time, for inciting
an insurrection.
And House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
made it official
by immediately
signing the document,
which will then be sent
to the Senate for a trial.
-Signing and certifying the bill
to make it official.
The Article of Impeachment
entitled
"Incitement of Insurrection."
There you see it, right there.
So it's a done deal, as far as
the House of Representatives
is concerned.
That document now will be
formally submitted
to the U.S. Senate,
where there will be a trial.
-I don't think
Pelosi intended this,
but it's a nice, little
troll of Trump
to hold up the document
for the cameras,
which was clearly one of his
favorite parts of the job.
He loved signing things
and then showing them off,
like he was doing story time
at the local library.
[ As Trump ]
"Does everyone see the duck?
Right there? And what
does the duck say, kids?
Quack? I don't think so,
but it's your dime."
So, the article will be sent
to the Senate for a trial,
which could happen immediately,
if Mitch McConnell were willing
to bring the Senate
back into session early.
You might remember McConnell
leaking to reporters
earlier this week that he was
pleased with impeachment
and considering
voting to convict Trump.
Well, as usual with McConnell,
it turned out that was
bull[bleep].
-Mitch McConnell just sent a
letter to his Senate colleagues
telling them that he will not
bring the Senate back early
before January 19th,
to reconvene the Senate.
Democrats wanted to have
a quick Senate trial,
have him convicted
before he leaves office.
That's not gonna happen.
-McConnell said he's undecided
about whether he'll
vote to convict Trump.
He said --
-Of course McConnell tried
to polish his reputation
by strategically
leaking to the media
that he was considering
convicting Trump,
and then when it came time
to actually do something,
chose the most craven
option available.
Trusting Mitch McConnell
to do the right thing
is like trusting Cujo
not to bite you.
[ As McConnell ] "Oh, just give
me a treat. I won't bite.
I'm a good boy.
Ha ha ha. Ha."
[ Normal voice ]
Also, what arguments
are you interested
in listening to?
Arguments like these?
-It's not just about
impeachment anymore.
It's about canceling,
as I've said.
Canceling the President
and anyone that
disagrees with them.
The Ayatollah can tweet.
The President can't.
-Robert De Niro said
that he wanted to punch
the president in the face.
Madonna thought about
blowing up the White House.
Kathy Griffin held up a likeness
of the President's
beheaded head.
-Some have cited the metaphor
that the President
lit the flame.
Well, they lit actual flames.
Actual fires.
-Rather than actually helping
American people in this time,
we start impeachments that
further divide our country.
I call bullcrap.
-Oh, you call "bullcrap?"
I didn't know you could invoke
your congressional power
of declaring playground law.
[ As Boebert ] "Not only
do I call bullcrap,
I regret to inform the Speaker
the the impeachment
has indeed bounced off of us
and now sticks to you!"
[ Normal voice ] By the way,
that's Lauren Boebert,
which also sounds
like a playground taunt.
"I'm not a Boebert!"
The congresswoman who has
bragged about her intention
to carry a gun in Congress,
and who defied
Capitol Police this week
after they asked
to search her bag.
And I just want to say,
you think carrying a gun around
makes you more free?
It makes everyone
else less free.
You get to cosplay
as a Wild West sheriff,
and everyone else has
to watch what they say,
because they're afraid of you.
That's not freedom,
it's intimidation.
I'm sorry, it pains me to say
this, but I have no choice --
I call bullcrap. Huhn-huhn-hunh.
Also, let's go to Matt Gaetz.
First of all,
your head looks like
the ash tray I made
in third grade.
And more importantly,
what are you talking about,
"Democrats lit actual flames?"
Are you insane?
It was Trump supporters who
stormed the Capitol,
ransacked the place,
left five people dead,
and tried to capture or
murder elected officials.
Just a note, Gaetz.
When you scream, you don't sound
as righteous
as you think you do.
You sound like an angry
frat dude telling the Dean
why it was actually Sigma Chi's
fault the Greek Row burned down.
[ As Gaetz ] "We had a small,
controlled fire pit
for our annual beach-themed
summer party,
but Sigma Chi lit actual flames
for their pig roast!
Also, they drew eyebrows
on our house dog!
Now Rufus looks like a dick!"
[ Normal voice ]
Although, I have to say,
my favorite example
of GOP psychosis yesterday
came from
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
whose name sounds like a child
actor from ABC'S TGIF lineup,
but is unfortunately a GOP
member of Congress
who has promoted the QAnon
conspiracy theory,
which the FBI has called
a domestic terror threat,
said there's an Islamic invasion
in the government,
held up an AR-15
in a campaign ad,
endangered her colleagues by
refusing to wear a mask
last week during
the Capitol lockdown,
and who voted to overturn
the election results
even after the riot last week.
-Democrats are on record
supporting violence
when it serves their cause,
in their own words,
on social media,
on interviews,
and on fundraising platforms.
-That's right, she's wearing
a mask that says "censored,
in case you couldn't read it
because of
the microphone in the way.
You know how dumb you look?
You're speaking on the floor
of the House of Representatives
and being broadcast
on national television.
It's like Lebron James
wearing a shirt that says,
"Play me, coach!"
These people will
stop at nothing
to make themselves
feel like victims.
It's all they have.
It's the core of their
political ideology.
They have no actual
policies or principles.
They just spin wild fantasies
of persecution,
and that's basically what Fox
News has been doing 24/7.
-We impeached the president
today without any evidence.
It's just sheer hatred.
If this becomes the norm,
be careful what
you wish for today.
Under this theory,
the radical left --
if you can impeach a president
after they're out of office,
why don't we impeach
George Washington?
He owned slaves.
Where does it stop?
-You see, the point is
to hold Trump accountable
for his actions
and disqualify him from
holding office again.
Washington is already
disqualified
on account of, spoiler alert,
being dead.
These guys love to just
make up insane fantasies,
because it's all they have.
They have no policy goals,
just scary, imagined grievances
to keep their base in line.
[ As Graham ] "Next, they're
gonna try to impeach
George Washington or
Thomas Jefferson
or Paul Blart, or maybe
they'll send Ernest to Jail.
Or, hell, even worse, maybe
they'll break Ernest out of jail
so his crime spree can continue.
I call bull crap, Sean."
[ Normal voice ] So, I guess
those are the kind of arguments
McConnell wants to hear
in the impeachment trial.
But even if McConnell
delays the trial
until after Trump leaves office,
it's still urgently necessary,
because if they convict him,
they can also disqualify him
from holding office ever again.
And you know Trump will
run again if he can.
Right now he's sitting
in the White House,
stewing by himself,
watching as they literally
load his [bleep] into boxes.
-Now, as the Trump
administration
enters its final stage,
the first sign of
the end of a presidency --
a moving van
outside the West Wing.
Stacks of moving boxes
were being delivered
to the Eisenhower
Executive Office Building.
The office will be
undergoing a deep cleaning
just before
President-elect Biden moves in.
There are very few people
left in this building,
and I can tell you that
having just walked through
the West Wing in the last hour,
the very few people
who are still here
are currently packing up
boxes in their offices.
-Trump's still president
for five more days,
but that place is emptier than
a rest stop Cinnabon at 3:00 AM.
And, man, I didn't think
anything could be more cathartic
than Trump losing
and getting impeached twice,
but actually, seeing the boxes
is pretty great.
Love to imagine Trump piling
all his stuff into crates --
his oversize suits,
his ties that are so long
that no matter how you pack
them, a little bit pokes out.
And I sure hope someone
is watching him pack,
because he's definitely
going to try to steal stuff.
"Sir, why is the bust of Lincoln
being packed away?"
[ As Trump ] "Uh, what?
No, this is mine from home.
I brought it. It's not
actually Lincoln.
It's my uncle, um...
Beard Trump.
Mel?
Mel, I need you
to vouch for the bust.
Mel?
We -- Mel?
What?
When did she leave?"
By the way, we we wrote
this joke right here,
about stealing the bust
this morning,
and then as often happens
in the Trump administration,
this afternoon,
this went down.
-We're seeing what looks
like moving day over here
at the White House.
You're seeing things, items,
coming and going
from the West Wing.
We saw Larry Kudlow
leaving earlier today.
Here's some video of
a bust of Abraham Lincoln
being carried out
of the West Wing.
-[ Chuckles ]
You know, who knows?
Maybe they're Purelling them,
you know?
Maybe they didn't want
even a bust of Lincoln
to see a grown man cry
in the Oval Office.
Or maybe, it's an O.J. situation
all over again.
That's right.
Just like O.J.,
they're going to nail Trump
for stealing memorabilia.
As the boxes arrive
and the specter
of a second impeachment trial
hangs over him,
it's hard to fully articulate
just how much of
a failure and disgrace
Trump will be
in the eyes of history.
Even if you just go
by the numbers alone,
Trump lost
the popular vote twice,
both times by millions of votes.
Got impeached twice.
He lost the House by
a record margin in 2018,
and he lost the Senate in 2021
by losing two seats
in what has for a long time
been a reliably red state.
Do you know how unpopular
you have to be as a Republican
to go 0-2 in Georgia?
Imagine if Democrats
lost control of the Senate
by going 0-2 in California.
James Carville would be on MSNBC
doing tequila shots,
crying into one of
his squashed-up hats
I'm assuming he stole
from the dumpster
behind a Louisiana thrift store.
What's with this guy?
He always looks
like a little kid
who wished on a monkey's paw
to be a grown-up.
[ As Carville ]
"Ah, cotswaddle!
Not like this!"
Oh, you win this round,
monkey paw!"
Oh, and on top of all that,
Trump has also overseen
the needless deaths
of hundreds of thousands
of Americans,
and will leave office
with 3 million fewer jobs
than when he took office --
by far the worst jobs record
in modern U.S. history.
Even if everything else
about him is forgotten
100 years from now,
those numbers will be
remembered forever.
When it's time to do
oral reports in history class,
every student
will want Trump
because it'll be
the easiest assignment.
"Michael, can you give us
FDR's accomplishments?"
"Well, he stopped
the Great Depression
and won World War II."
"Okay, but you forgot
a few things, so, B-.
And Timmy,
can you tell us about
Donald Trump's
accomplishments?"
"He was friends
with Grimace."
"A-plus, Timmy.
You got it all.
You could learn a thing
or two from Timmy, Michael."
And yet, the harsh reality
that we must reckon with
is that,
with only a few exceptions,
the Republican Party
spent the last four years
colluding with
this evil.
And they knew
it was evil.
Ted Cruz, Marco Rubio,
Rick Perry, Lindsey Graham,
Nikki Haley --
they all saw it.
They even warned us about it
during the primaries --
before deciding to shame
themselves, and join in.
And even now, the vast majority
of the Republican Party
remains in the grip
of a mass delusion
it refuses to shake --
the delusion that motivated
last week's attack --
that Trump
won the election,
and that Joe Biden
is illegitimate.
These people have devoted
themselves to the Trump cult.
But if there's one thing
we've learned, it's that,
no matter how much loyalty
you show him,
he's never, ever,
ever gonna repay it.
I mean, look what he did
to Mike Pence,
or how about
his personal lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani, the man who
single-handedly led the charge
to get the election overturned
by flying from state to state,
holding press conferences
at landscaping companies,
and meeting with every
drunk loon he could find?
Obviously,
it was all a grift.
Rudy was reportedly
billing Trump $20,000 a day.
And guess what?
Trump doesn't want to pay.
-President Trump is reportedly
taking out his frustrations
on his personal attorney,
Rudy Giuliani,
by refusing to pay him
for his legal services.
The Washington Post is reporting
that President Trump
is trying to
stiff Giuliani,
who has spent
the past few months
traveling the country, and
spreading conspiracy theories
about the November election
on behalf of the president.
Giuliani is seeking
$20,000 per day in fees.
The newspaper says the president
has not only refused to pay
Giuliani's legal fees,
but has told aides that
all reimbursement requests
for travel and other expenses
need to go through him.
-Impeachment was great,
but there really is
no more perfect way for this
to end than Trump stiffing Rudy.
The guy spent all that time
flying to state capitols,
rounding up witnesses
from the bars
at TGI Fridays
and Buffalo Wild Wings,
and now, Trump won't even
reimburse him.
[ As Trump ]
"Also, you owe me for the time
I called into the hearing.
It went over
on minutes.
Because, Rudy, you're not
friends, and you're not family,
so those minutes
are costly."
[ Normal voice ]
And poor Rudy needed that money
for the hair transplant.
[ As Giuliani ]
"Please, boss, I'm begging you,
don't make me go back
to the mud water."
[ Normal voice ]
This is like the end
of "The Sixth Sense,"
but instead
of Bruce Willis
realizing he's been dead
the whole time,
it's Donald Trump realizing
that Rudy has,
the whole time,
been a bad lawyer.
[ As Trump ]
"Oh, no.
Wait a second.
He was a bad lawyer."
[ Normal voice ]
Nothing Trump or Republicans
say or do from here on out
should be taken seriously,
unless they uniformly
and unequivocally
acknowledge the reality
that the election
was not rigged,
and that Joe Biden won,
and apologize for their roles
in spreading lies
and conspiracy theories
fomenting the insurrection
we saw last week.
Unfortunately,
as we saw yesterday,
too many of them have walled
themselves off from reality.
They live in a deranged
fantasy world of grievance,
and victimhood, lies,
conspiracy theories,
and...
-Bullcrap.
This has been
"A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask. We love you.